and now to deliver a very timely talk
i'd like to welcome
faith and i derek
thanks brady hello my name is leia
snyderich and i am writing a novel set
in the future for my novel i'm
researching ectogenesis which is my
topic for today
ectogenesis is the development of a
mammalian embryo in an artificial
environment
so since i'm a writer i'm going to tell
you a story as a way to explain it and
it begins in the year
kanye kirchhoff is a pregnant 40 year
old phd candidate
she wants to finish her thesis before
her child is born
the title of her thesis is ectogenesis
is it as easy as one two three
at almost two months pregnant kanye
writes a very strong chapter on the
first researchers to successfully grow
these lambs in bio bags from the human
equivalent of 23 weeks to full term
kanye wonders how she's going to weave
in when private funding started she
cites this tweet from elon musk who's
worried about population collapse and an
advertising ceo's response synthetic
looms
kanya's ring vibrates and she switches
on her vr and walks into her doctor's
appointment
although natural birth is still
technically legal kanye's doctor is
shocked to see a six-week-old embryo on
the ultrasound
in year 2052 it is barbaric to suffer
through pregnancy her doctor reminds her
of the safety of ectogenesis and the
equality among genders and sexual
minorities that it's given the world
this is all true but kanye just finished
a chapter of the
long ago cesarean section
that increased at an alarming rate not
because of improved outcomes but because
of legal and economic conditions of the
time
was it just yesterday that kanye opened
her feed to see womb tech stock
increased 50 percent
kanye's friends enjoyed watching their
fetuses grow on the live stream
but once they picked up their babies at
the wombtech warehouses they still
struggled with
age-old issues like
affordable health care and child care
and equal division of domestic labor
nonetheless
her friends were surprised that kanye
decided to go against the mainstream
they asked her if she thought her body
would remember how to give birth they
told her that she was brave
kanye tried to remember when public
opinion started to shift and she found
this date in 2021
when the international society for stem
cell research lifted the 14 day limit on
human embryo research kanye wrote about
the first x utero machines to grow mouse
fetuses with a heartbeat not much
different from the ones developed by
wound tech today
but in 2030 public opinion really
shifted with these machines that started
saving millions of premature infants as
early as 23 weeks
maybe kanye was an outlier
but she thought her friends were the
brave ones until synthetic eggs passed
clinical trials that eggs supporting
wombtech inc were extracted from human
bodies
how many injections did her friends
agree to
was it 60 hours of procedures and
doctors visits
kanye wasn't convinced that ectogenesis
was as easy as one two three
as unpopular as it was
kanye wanted a natural birth
she wanted the benefits to her brain and
her child's brain and she really just
wanted people to trust her ability to
make good decisions for herself
as her pregnancy became noticeable
social and legal pressures increased
her doctor threatened to call child
protective services unless she
transitioned her pregnancy to an
artificial womb
so kanye was forced to hide which proved
very productive for her writing she
completed her thesis and when her baby
was born she described it as
pure reverence
back at work
kanya breast-fed in the meditation room
a gift in 2052
that less than one percent
of people could give their children
thank you so much
thank you so much status
um
what did you see as the relation between
this talk and your book
yeah so the inspiration um for my book
was uh
this new science coming out and uh
imaginary vision of a warehouse
full of
babies growing in
artificial wombs
so
i wrote from that
visual
all right
well thank you very much for being with
us today theath
thank you brady
you